hide the lining this Chris Slade and one
of my goals in life is to help bridge
the gap between science and the modern
Christian what is there that I could say
to help convince others that the
creation story is likely just a story
that was told to people who wouldn't
have understood the complexities of
science as we do today I just want to
show people that their religious beliefs
don't need to be dependent on ignoring
science Chris your religious beliefs
don't need don't depend on ignoring
science yeah well you hope not so just
from my point of view Chris keep in mind
I'm a mechanical engineer I took nothing
but physics I love science science is
what enabled us to create this computer
communication system and this electronic
infrastructure without science you
couldn't do this and you use the word
Christian so specifically there's
nothing in the New Testament of the
Bible about electrons or protons or
transistor transistor logic or even
modern or maybe most especially modern
agriculture or genes or DNA ores and so
on so the question is if if you have a
religious tenant if you hold a point of
view that excludes something about
modern science I don't think the burden
is on scientists or engineers to provide
you a comfortable link the link is for
you you have to reckon the facts as we
call them with some belief system that
is incompatible with it an example that
I think everybody would eventually find
ourselves discussing would be geology
the age of the earth you know a couple
years ago I debated a guy who insists
that the earth is 6,000 years old that's
completely wrong that's obviously wrong
and the way we know it is wrong was a
centuries was a result of centuries of
study people found layers of rocks
figured out where the layer
came from people found radioactive
elements which chemically substitute
into certain crystals for in exchange
like rubidium and strontium substitute
for potassium and calcium and put argon
and so on and these this led us to an
understanding of the age of the earth so
if you have a belief system that is
incompatible with modern geology the
really Chris the problem is for the
person trying to argue the earth is
extraordinarily young not for the people
who have studied the world around us and
understand it with that set religions in
my experience give people this important
sense of community the reason in my
experience that people my age whatever
go to church is to be with other people
at least let's say let's say once a week
and that is of great value the
communities of great value but there's
nothing there that I have seen in the
Bible that informs modern science with
one possible exception there's in some
translations that I've read there's
reference to 22 sevenths for being the
distance around a circle the value of
pi' and that's pretty close that's
pretty close it's not it doesn't go past
three digits place pretty close okay so
these the people who wrote the Bible
where they were literate but they were
not literate in the modern scientific
sense so you have to reckon that man I
can't I can't get in there the Earth's
not 6,000 years old never gonna be and
then share your community and celebrate
it carry on
you